[音楽]
なんでこんなとこにいるんだろう
他社は何やってんだろう
何の為に生まれて何をして生きる
そんなの知って何になるの
みんなは普通に就職して
ちゃんと生きてんのに
本当に私何やってんだろう
バカみたい
これはまさに4年前の今日
地球の裏側のペルーの私の状態でした
英語もしゃべれない
スペイン語も話せない
宛先も行き先もない
海外も初めての一人旅です
地図も持っていませんでした
地図といえばこんな小さな
旅先であった423という人がくれた
こんな小さな地図を持って私は一人旅をしていました
何の為に生まれて何をして生きるのか
そう書いたノートを握りしめて
人は
なんで来てるんだろう
私たちはどこから来て
どこへ行くの
世界は
なんで平和にならないんだろう
そんなことを
考えたことありませんか
私は幼い頃からずっとそんなことばっかり考えてる子供でした
世界のどこかにその答えがあるかもしれない
宇宙のどこかにその答えがあるかもしれない
不変のしぇんでー
もしかしたら答えかもしれない
そう思っていました
そんなこといいよ
そんなことを考えて何になるんだもっと気楽に k 8
そういうふうに言われるかもしれません
だけど私は無理でした
私はそれを知らないと生きていけない
そんな想いでした
だってどこかに平和の答えや私たちが生きている答えが絶対あるような気がして
だから大人になっても
そんな途方もない根源的な疑問
ずっと諦めずにいました
そして4年前の今
このように
私はペレーニ一人旅に行ってたんです
さて
皆さんは旅に出たことありますか
忘れられない旅をしたことありますか
旅ではなくても人生でこの期間だけはどうしても忘れられない
そんな思い出があると思います
私のペルーの旅はまさにそれでした
ネットもないパソコンもない携帯も使えません
地図を持ってないんです
途中で google 先生にこう頼るわけにもいかい行きません
なんにも耐えるものがなくなったとき
私が倒れる者は私自身でした
私はだんだん自分自身を信じ始めていました
そして私がすべて知る必要はなかったんです
なぜなら必ず世界が教えてくれたから
私は困ったとき
必ず誰かが助けてくれました
どうしても次の行き先が分からなくなったとき
あなたまであと男の子がその行き先を導いてくれることもありました
その行った先が本当にあっているか分からなかったとき
1本の大きな木がここであってるよという目印になりました
どうしても悩んで悩んで
その答えが見つからなかったとき
村人の男の子のその日見た夢が私の答えになったりもしました
そんな風に
私は食べ酒で必ず何かサインのような目印を見つけていきました
それを前兆と呼んでいました
私はその前兆一つ
二つ一
打つと
違っていきます
だんだん全長読むのが上手くなってくるんです
そして船長たとってたどり着いたとき
ガイドブックにも載ってないような
ペルーの小さな村ですたん
そこのままで
私はシャーマンにあります
3万とは
私たちは生きているうちについつい忘れてしまう
大切なことを思い出させてくれる存在です
何の為に生まれて何をして生きるのかもしかしたらその答えが見つかるかもしれない
私はそう思って
さあ manic に参加することにしました
それは
10年前
1月の
大きな満月の日でした
私の全てを粒子になりました
めっ
穴口
てっ
私がこの確かだと思っていたこの世界を感じていた感覚がすべて変わってしまったん
です
怖くてこうやって身体を触ります一生懸命変わるんです
だけど
あっている
それが何だったのかわからなくなりました
あって今日見るんです一生懸命
目で見るんですよちゃんと見ている
だけど
見る
という感覚もわかりません
私の世界はいらいら異例
またかたまぎぃ
また枚入れてきました
全てのものの境界線を曖昧なりー
私ら自分をというのもわからなくなりました
あれっどこまでが自分えっ待って自分
自分ってなんだっけ
そういうふうに
わからないんです
私の世界に
確かなものはなくなりました
そのとき思ったんです
私は今までこの世界も
人も
私自身が確かだと思っていた
すべてのものはこの私という感覚を通したですか
見たことがなかった
すべては私が見ていた世界だったかもしれない
もしかしたら
1000部
夢だったのかもしれない
そのとき私は目の前から大きな大きなことクリ飲み込まれてしまいました
孤独ですたん
一人ぼっちですと
全て一つなので
私しかいません
そしてその時
すべては
想い通りになる世界で
たってすべては一つだから
だから本当は99%が奇跡なんだ
そして
一方セントの想い鳥の案内世界のほうがいい
本当はこの現実のほうが奇跡だったんだ
なんだ
そうだったんだ
私はますもしてもう一度生きれるなろ
こうやってこの上でしっかりと人を抱きしめたい
声があるうちに愛してるよ大好きだよ
寂しい悲しい辛い
今の痛い
この目で
この目でほしい月
自然
あたりない場合のものをきれいなものを見ていきたい
なんでそれができなかったんだろう
もう1回もう1回狙う叶うなら a
私は生きることまた選びなおしたい
や額やりたい選ぶんだ
奇跡の中でもう1回選ぶんだ
もう1回奇跡の中を生きるんだ
そう思った時
ゾーンと体にすごい重力がかかり
私は戻ってきました
それから私の人生はどうなったでしょうか
それは生き直したかのように全く別物になりました
日常がキセキざと思い思えるようになったのです
だけど何の為に生まれて何をして生きるのか
その答えを知りたくて体験したんです
の答えていうのは人は
孤独ということ
結局全部夢だったっていうこと
私は自分が体験した
その答えをどうやって受け取っていいのかわからなくなりました
そしてまた探しに行ったんです
撃っちゃうかもっていないならや撃っちゃうかそういう答えなら
もしかしたら神様を違う答えを持っているかもしれない
重い他社インドに来ました
不変の戦では違う答えがあるかもしれない
そう思い中に長いミスをしたこともあります
誰かかこの人が偉い誰かが
答えを持っているかもしれない
そして私は世界中が探し回りました
そして待っていました
私の全ての体験が経験が
そしてたくさんの気づきが私の中で一つになっていくの
そしてやっとです水にです
答えを見つけたんです
ずっと探していたウッズの世界の答えです
平和になる緒かもしれません
それは
うっ中には
世界には
答えがないということでした
答えはなかったんです
誰も
世界の答えになって乗ってはいませんでした
宇宙は世界は自由自在
何でもなりえたのです
答えがない何にもないというのが答えではありません
宇宙は
なんでもいいんだよ
なんでもいい
そう言っていつも行手を広げて待っていてくれたんです
私が地球の裏側にまでいって答えを探しに行った時も
一体どれ剤なんだろう
この世界は愛なんかないんじゃないか
人は結局孤独かもしれない
そういうふうに思った時も片時も見放さずずっと愛してくれていました
それは幾重にも幾重にも重なった
途方もない愛でした
なんでもいいんだよなんでもいい
答えなんてないんだから
その時やっとわかったんです
また菅
本当に知りたかったのは
うっちゅうや世界や不変の真理らー
そういう答えではなかったということ
私は
誰かに言ってほしかった
本当はねええ
世界は愛で出来てるんだよ
どんな世界であってもそれは愛で出来ているんだよ
本当はねぇ
どんな人も愛なんだよええ
誰もが愛から生まれたんだよ
私たちは自由なんだ
何からも縛られていない
私はそう言ってほしかった宇宙残ったや世界の答えが普遍の真理がそうだと
そういうのが答えだと言ってほしかった
だけど
宇宙には答えはありませんでした
別注は世界は私が
世界は愛なんだ
そう選ぶのをずっと待っていてくれたんです
世界の平和になる答え
答えはないのでそれは分かりません
だけど分かったことあります
あれば私たちは
今
ここからいつでも選び直せるということです
過去や未来はありません
今ここしかないのですここですか
いつも怒っていないのです
少し考えてみてください
自分の生い立ち
どんな過去がありますか
どんな経験をしましたかちょっと考えてみてください
今度はもっと大きいところに行きます
この世界は今どんな風になっていますか
いい方向にいってますか悪い方向にいってますか
自分の国は
はいそして戻ってきてください
今ココです
私たちは過去歴史
そういうものは全てこの記憶の中にあるんです
さっきみたいに今ここから私たちはいつも見渡すことができる
私たちが今自由に
最善を自由に選べるように
過去や歴史経験それは今を選ぶ
材料でしかないのです
過去は
私たちを縛ることではありません歴史も繰り返すものではありません
私たちのすべてのこの今のためにあったのです
では少しみんなで描きなおしてみませんか
少し目をつぶってください
画面の向こうの人も目をつぶってください
自分のインナースペースに聞いてみてください
なったか
本当はこんな世界だったらいいのに
本当はこんな人生だったらいいのに
本物ありませんか
自由に仕事ができたらいいなぁ
も退社って期待具体的なこともあるかもしれない
だけどもっと感覚的なことかもしれない人とつながりやっていきたい
をもやって来たいもっと優しい世界に行きたいもっとクリエイティブに期待
平和に生きたい
はい目を開けてください
もし何かこう行きたい
こういう世界だったらいいのにそういうものがあるなら
そしてそれを誰かに
それでいいよと言ってほしかったら
私たちは今ここから選ぶことができる
そして世界や宇宙が答えを持っていません
あなたがそう生きるその答えをみんな待っています
世界に絶望するなら私たちが希望歩けばいい
生きたい人生がこの世界ないなら私たちがそう生きてその答えを作ればいい
何の為に生まれて何をしできるのか答えられないなんてやだ
これは私の長い長いと位でした
そしてこれからも答えなきと言わ
鈴テープでしょう
だけど
私はもう決めた
答えがある世界はもう終わり
宇宙の答え探しはもうおしまい
私は
自分の人生をプラ4と会いしながら生きていきたい
だって愛でできたこの世界を愛するために生まれてきたんだから
[拍手]
[音楽]